so Doctor Who is going to Disney Plus in  2023 and whilst the production is still  going to be handled by Bad Wolf The  distribution is going to be handled by  Disney plus meaning that anyone in the  world is going to be able to watch  Doctor Who on the day of release which  is huge for international audiences who  if you're not in the UK will have had to  wait a couple of days maybe a week maybe  a month maybe a year before you got to  watch the episode of Doctor Who and you  were probably spoiled on Twitter about  what had actually happened  is this going to be good I think it's  going to be good for that very reason  but also the investment that Disney is  going to be making in Doctor Who higher  budget is going to look amazing I just  hope it doesn't detract from the story  I don't want them to do what they did to  Star Wars  please don't do that please